it is september 13 2022 and you're
watching the code report last friday i
made a video about firebase alternatives
and you guys were quick to let me know
that i left out a very important project
called pocketbase well i tried it out
and it kind of blew my mind
as soon as i landed on the home page and
saw this cool proximity hover effect
where the eyes follow your cursor i was
sold on it at first glance it looks very
similar to supabase something with a
real-time relational database
authentication file storage and so on
that's built entirely with open source
software unlike the godfather firebase
which requires proprietary google
software it looks like other bases at
first glance but it's actually very
different under the hood and i think it
has the potential to be the ultimate
side project back end let's go ahead and
compare it to something like supabase
the first thing you'll notice is that
it's written in the go programming
language as opposed to typescript for
supabase that's mostly superficial but
things in go do tend to be faster it
also uses svelte for its admin ui while
supabase uses react and firebase uses
angular that's totally meaningless but
just kind of interesting for client-side
sdks it supports javascript and dart
which means it's usable on web desktop
and mobile what's really interesting
about pocketbase though is the database
instead of something like postgres or
mysql it directly embeds sql lite into
the executable and runs it in wall mode
which stands for right ahead logging my
initial thought was you can't use sql
light in production but actually that's
a misconception sequel light is an
underappreciated option for small to
medium sized projects surprisingly in
wall mode it actually outperforms other
relational databases especially in a
read heavy app and i'm sure it'll work
perfectly fine for your side project
that's destined to fail but in the off
chance it doesn't fail you might be
wondering does pocket base scale because
the database is embedded into the
runtime itself it can only scale
vertically this differs from nosql
databases like firestore that use
sharding to scale horizontally to an
infinite number of machines when scaling
vertically the only way to handle more
traffic is to use a bigger computer as
the app grows you'll need to add more
cpu and more ram but you can only do
that for so long like the biggest
computer you can rent on aws has a 128
cpu cores and about 2 terabytes of ram
and the rent is about the same as a bay
area studio apartment in any case
scaling vertically will work for 99 of
apps out there pocket base can easily
handle tens of thousands of concurrent
real-time connections on a single five
dollar vm on digitalocean or something
like that which brings me to the next
point pocketbase is entirely
self-hostable in fact you have to
self-host it whereas most people using
supabase are using its fully managed 25
bucks a month service and it's also been
criticized for being extremely difficult
to self-host like you've got eight
different services to think about here
in the docker compose if anybody here is
self-hosting superbase in production
please leave a comment and let me know
how it went for you what's really unique
about pocketbase is that it results in a
single executable which makes it very
simple to deploy another important
difference is that when it comes to
backend code you can just extend the
framework directly with go then that
code will be right there in the
executable right next to your database
in other words you build a monolith as
opposed to a bunch of different micro
services that run on fancy edge
functions in fact an architecture like
this tends to be faster than the edge
when data fetching is involved as i
proved in this video with flat earth
science i think the bottom line here is
that pocket base is like a lightweight
superbase alternative which itself is
the open source firebase alternative
which itself is the alternative to
building your own back end from scratch
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one